-Our next guests received three
Grammy nominations between them,
including Best Country Album.
Performing "Gospel Night at the
Strip Club," with John Osborne,
from her album "Lindeville,"
please welcome Ashley McBryde.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ It's gospel night
at the strip club ♪
♪ I've been sleepin' in my car ♪
♪ I lead the singin' service
with a half-ass-tuned guitar ♪
♪ Brandy's singin' backup ♪
♪ Lonnie tendin' bar ♪
♪ I'm just waitin'
for more sinners to show up ♪
♪♪
♪ Crystal just started dancin' ♪
♪ She's always right on point ♪
♪ She don't mind
if you don't tip her ♪
♪ Long as you slip her a joint ♪
♪ Patti's got an upper ♪
♪ To get her through her shift ♪
♪ And a downer so she can
lay down with the kids ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Jesus loves the drunkards
and the whores and the queers ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Would you recognize him ♪
♪ If he bought you a beer ♪
♪ Lonnie, he's a listener ♪
♪ He shoulda been a priest ♪
♪ But it's the same confession ♪
♪ On a barstool or your knees ♪
♪ He makes a mean Manhattan,
but he ain't drank since '93 ♪
♪ He does
the last call benediction ♪
♪ Then wipes
the bar slate clean ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Jesus loves the drunkards
and the whores and the queers ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Would you recognize him ♪
♪ If he bought you a beer ♪
♪♪
♪ The same old dirty dollars ♪
♪ Just keep
gettin' passed around ♪
♪ To whoever needs it most ♪
♪ I guess that's me right now ♪
♪ I'm starin' at this Jackson
somebody laid here at my feet ♪
♪ That's gas in my old Honda ♪
♪ And somethin' warm to eat ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
-♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Jesus loves the drunkards
and the whores and the queers ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
-♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Would you recognize him ♪
♪ If he bought you a beer ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
-♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ Jesus loves the drunkards
and the whores and the queers ♪
♪ Hallelujah ♪
-♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ He laid down a twenty ♪
♪ And then he disappeared ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.